hello grammarians previously I had
covered three of the basic aspects of
English and that's simple perfect and
progressive and so there's just one more
and it's a combination of the last two
and it's called the perfect progressive
and to recap what those two things do is
what the perfect does is it denotes
something that is complete and the
progressive notes something that has
been ongoing and it seems like those two
things together don't make a whole lot
of sense but I promise that they do you
can use the perfect progressive aspect
to say that you've been doing something
for a long time or you will have done
something for a long time or that you
had been doing something continuously in
the past and now it's stopped so let me
explain how the perfect progressive is
constructed do you take the verb to have
and then you combine it with the word
bin and then the verb in question and
then the ending I n G so as with all of
our aspects the only part that changes
is this have stuff this is the this is
the only word that changes depending on
which tense you situated in so in the
past you would say I had I had been
eating cookies in the present you would
say I have been eating cookies in the
future you can say I will have been
eating cookies so you can use the
perfect progressive aspect in a couple
of different ways you can say that
something had been ongoing in the past
and is now done you can say that it's
been ongoing in the past and is still
happening now you know I have been
eating cookies all morning and I have no
intent to stop or you can use the
perfect progressive to say how long
something has been going on so you can
say I've been eating I will have been
eating cookies for 40 years come next
Thursday and I have no regrets you know
you can say how long something has been
going on using this aspect but you get
the idea so the perfect progressive is
formed by combining have and have is the
part that changes I had been I have been
I will have been with bin and the verb
in question with an ING ending you can
learn anything Dave it out